call our stuff meat-free meat it's not a
meat alternative I call it a meats
improvement
it's
jail was in college and I called them
one day and I said hey you should quit
college and open up a vegan butcher shop
I was on my way out anyway all of our
stuff looks like the real thing tastes
exactly like the real thing so people
hardly know the difference a lot of our
meats are wheat base it's a high protein
wheat flour about 95 percent 14 5
percent private and when you mix it with
water various juices and things it
develops to a very thick muscular dough
that can be shaped into steaks sausages
to anything you can use different juices
vinegars different flours so it creates
really any texture any flavor really
really easy meat but you can think of we
definitely know that our customer base
is about 60 to 70 percent omnivores
there's like a shift of empathy you know
people are starting to each with their
morals and you know with their
conscience
how we come up with the ideas for the
meats and cheeses that we have in the
case it's kind of what we're hungry for
and also what our customers ask for